that's hard I mean yoga philosophy is my
philosophy and what yoga philosophy says
simply is you are it and this is it
there's no other place and there's no
other you I I think that that's my
personal philosophy too is that I'm not
looking for someone to save me or to
save the world I am the one I've been
waiting for and we are the ones we've
been waiting for you know so often today
in these troubled times I hear well we
need to educate the children we need to
get the young people interested in
global warming and in overpopulation and
then in the troubling things in the
world and then they'll fix it in their
time I don't believe that I believe that
action needs to be taken now and the
only thing stopping us from acting is
our basically we've given up on
ourselves and we feel our time is over
well it's not over the change could be
instantaneous and that is my philosophy
I I believe that I felt the
instantaneous change that is that just
changing your mind and that's that's
what I try to do I try to change my mind
a lot and I try to change it back to its
original nature not a not a covering
over with reaction
sure I mean faith is an essential
element of the yogic path since we are
dealing with a realm that is unseen
it depends to a large extent on faith on
the other hand the yogic techniques do
give you experiences that verify the
existence of these these unseen realms
so faith is important maybe at some
point religions have done well in the
world but I think that that today
they've lost their usefulness and
they've created many wars and
disturbances in the world and we need to
get back to the basics and that's why
religions were created in the first
place not to control people but to give
people a way to exercise they their
inspiration and to become inspired to
connect to each other to gather together
and to form political action groups and
and community service groups I think
these are the good parts of organized
religions the bad parts are are the many
wars that are fought over religion and
the and the disagreements that people
have over